importance of recovery within your
training program and this by the way
this is from sore necks the guys that
make weight racks yeah well you know for
for recovery to be important you have to
have done the hard work to need it so I
think a lot of people focus on recovery
all the time when they seriously I can't
do that today I'm on recovery yeah I
think I got a crop therapy or ice bath
or get a massage or acupuncture you know
like [ __ ] go train hard you know like
these calluses I cut off you know what
weakly it's from hard work you know and
and I think recovery is as important as
training but first the training has to
be there and it has to be hard enough
for it to warrant needy and recovery
yeah and I was I always say when when
I'm when I was training fighters I don't
do it a lot anymore but when I was
training for UFC fighters
it was so obvious when they were over
trained like they'd go from the you know
they'd be giving me a hard time on the
mat or whatever and all of a sudden I'm
just annihilating them and I go yeah hey
day off man go eat two steaks tomorrow
and just relax easy but you know some
guys oh I needed a couple days off you
need a day off I think it has more to do
with lifestyle than recovery you know
like when people are like hey I'm just
not being able to put that get the
output the volume that I need to do for
work let's talk about your life you know
like we all chase and [ __ ] last night
oh you were you or you're at a strip
club is that glitter or suck get out get
what have you eaten this week tell me
show me your diet did you even have a
log no you don't have a log get out you
know how much did you sleep last night
oh you don't know who's what you drank
get out you know like when was the last
time you had a drink
Oh last night get out you know stop
talking to me about recovery if you
don't have a lifestyle that's conducive
to training you know like you don't talk
about healthy lifestyle get eight hours
of sleep well get yeah I know yeah hey
Jacque what doesn't sleep a lot that's
all right it's all right eat real food
stop putting crap in your body stop
drinking you know you'll drop you
drone you would talk about these guys at
having like a huge problems to stop what
one stopped using steroids to stop
drinking you know for me sex day every
day get it hours of sleep work my ass
off I think that a man for a real
athlete man a woman they have to go to
bed tired I love that feeling
what like you are exhausted you see that
bed and you're like can I make it okay I
make it from the shower to bed yeah
that's what you're supposed to feel like
we've talked about that on here that's
that's one of my favorite feelings in
the world of I get to the end of the
night and I'm barely hanging on through
dinner and by the time I get done with
God can't wait wife starts talking
you're like baby wah wah wah wah wah wah
wah wah and hear the words but I don't
know what you're saying
yeah you know so I yeah that's that's
great input sleep eat right but you can
work man humans can do a lot it's the
body is so adaptive so so you got people
that can run ultra marathons and they
got people that can deadlift thousands
of pounds the and were the same species
right you know we have people that can
like paint the Mona Lisa and there's
people that can go in murder villages
same species you know like it is an
adaptive thing as long as you train it
properly